[Music]
our country itself is safe
but it's lost its sense of direction
even its common decent you don't so much
as regular fingers
[Applause]
there's a lot of people saying a lot of
things
but in the end you gotta listen to
yourself
in that moment
elvis the man was sacrificed
and elvis the god was
you're looking for born
you came to the right place
you're looking for trouble
look right in my face
[Music]
he had no idea what he had done
[Applause]
i wish to promote you mr presley
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't do the business the business
will do you
i'm gonna do what i want to do sing the
music that i want
i get it
[Music]
they're gonna put me in jail
what are you saying is god-given
so there can't be nothing wrong with it
if you don't listen to me
that your mama has sacrificed for you
would be for nothing
trust me
[Applause]
i don't want to talk about the new elvis
[Applause]
never met anyone like you i hope not
[Music]
without me there would be no end
my things are too dangerous to say
sing
ladies and gentlemen here's elvis
presley
[Music]
this ain't no nostalgia show
we're gonna do something
different
[Music]
you